john wick suffering fighting for freedom
keanu is our ultimate crush whether he's
got us on the edge of our seats and john
wick doc five seconds three
two
and the way we go
or showing off his comedic talents in
bill and ted yeah
we did
most important question keanu have your
air guitar skills improved over the past
three decades uh no i've never been very
good at air guitar but
what i lack in talent i
now i probably don't even make up an
enthusiasm
and who can forget mr eugene levy we are
oh so lucky to call this comedic genius
our own i mean american pie anyone
this is just a bad reception oh baby
what's that you know what dude just uh
give me this one and let's get this oh
the hell's the matter with this thing
here and let's not forget a little show
called shit's creek what is your
favorite season
awards
speaking of eugene his on-screen wife
katherine o'hara is a canadian hero all
on her own watching catherine work is is
something else and she's just so gifted
and she's so funny and she does have a
very natural charm so pumped can't you
see it in my face it's great i even
dressed up for it
imagine oh that the day did have a
slight cigal test what's she talking
about a hiccup what hiccup who's
hiccuping
[Music]